OKAY, GENERAL CLARK, YOU SAID
RECENTLY THAT THE WORLD SHOULD
BE IN YOUR WORDS EXPECTING A
FRUSTRATED PUTIN TO DO
SOMETHING.
CAN YOU ELABORATE ON WHAT YOU
MEAN AND ALSO HOW WOULD YOU, IF
YOU WERE IN YOUR PRIOR POST, AS
NATO SUPREME ALLIED COMMANDER,
HOW WOULD YOU BE PREPARING FOR
THAT?
>> WELL, I THINK, FIRST OF ALL,
YOU HAVE TO ANTICIPATE WHAT HE
MIGHT DO.
SO THE USE OF CHEMICAL WEAPONS
SEEMS TO BE A LITTLE BIT
PREMATURE, EXCEPT PERHAPS IN
GOING AFTER MARIUPOL.
BUT IT IS NOT THAT SIGNIFICANT.
SO I THINK THE CHEMICAL WEAPONS
THREAT IS A MORE FAR FETCHED
THREAT.
IF HE REALLY WANTS TO DETER NATO
INVOLVEMENT AND HE BELIEVES THAT
HE CAN SHATTER NATO, THEN HE
WOULD PERHAPS USE A LOW YIELD
NUCLEAR WEAPON.
AND WHERE WOULD HE USE IT?
PROBABLY NOT IN UKRAINE, BUT
PERHAPS ON THE STAGING AREAS OR
SOME POPULATED AREA IN POLAND.
THIS IS WHAT IS USUALLY DONE IN
THE RUSSIAN EXERCISES.
SO THE WAY THEY POST LATE IN
THEIR EXERCISES IS THAT IF
RUSSIA STARTS TO USE BECAUSE OF
NATO SUPPORT FOR THE OPPOSITION,
THEN, POW, THEY SEND A NUCLEAR
WEAPON IN, NATO SAYS, MY
GOODNESS, WE DON'T WANT A
NUCLEAR WAR, THAT WOULD BE A
THIRD WORLD WAR, OKAY, SINCE
YOU'RE THAT SERIOUS ABOUT IT,
WE'LL BACK OFF.
SO THIS IS THE WAY THE RUSSIANS
HAVE EDUCATED THEMSELVES TO
THINK ABOUT WHAT THEY WOULD DO
IN A